اسطوره صحفيه قتلها خساره ماساويه واهانه
لحريه الاعلام بهذه الكلمات علق البيت
الابيض على اغتيال الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مراسله الجزيره شيرين ابو عاقله اتبعت
واشنطن تنديرها القويه هذا بدعوه لاجراء
ما وصفاته بتحقيق مستفيظ لكشف حقيقه ما
جرى في مخيم جنين صبيحه الحادي عشر من
مايو ايار 2022
اذانه الجريمه وتحقيق شامل وشفاف عليهما
توالت واجمعت ردود الفعل الدوليه عربيا
وعالميا
بعد شهرين من الحادثه وتحريدا في يوليو
2022 اعلنت واشنطن انها طلعت على تحقيقين
منفصلين اجراهم الجيش الاسرائيلي والسلطه
الفلسطينيه وعليهما رجحت انه لا يوجد اي
سبب للاعتقاد بان مقتل شيرين كان متعمدا
بل هو نتيجه لما وصفتها بظروف ماساويه
خلال عمليه عسكريه راء الفلسطينيون الامر
انحيازا الامريكيا لاسرائيل ومحاوله
لتبرئتها من دمشرين محملين اسرائيل
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الجريمه وداع
الفلسطينيون الى تحقيق محايد ليؤكد
الحقيقه المؤكده لديهم ان شيرين قتلت بدم
بارد برصاصه جندي اسرائيلي غير ان الموقف
الامريكيه شهد تحولا معاكسا حين كشفت
وسائل اعلام امريكيه انا مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي الاف بي اي فتحها تحقيقا في
مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله
اسباب كثيره قد تكون وراء التحول هذا فهو
ياتي بعد عده تحقيقات مستقله من جهات
دوليه منها الامم المتحده وصحف غربيه
مرموقه كوشنتن بوست ويورك تايمز وبكاله
السوشيرت خلصت جميعها الى تورط اسرائيل في
اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقل كما انه استجابه
لعشرات من النواب الديمقراطيين في
الكونجرس وقعوا عريضه تطالب مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي باجراء تحقيق مستقلا
في مقتل شيرين ابو عاقله التي تحمل
الجنسيه الامريكيه تتحرك الجزيره كي تقاضي
يا اسرائيل امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مدفوعه بادله جديده تظهر ان شيرين
وزملائها الصحفيين تعرضوا لاطلاق نار
مباشر من الاحتلال واللجوء للجنائيه
الدوليه خطوه رفضتها واشنطن واثارت غضبا
في تل ابيب
اسرائيل توعدت بانه لن يستجوب اي من
جنودها يقول رئيس الاسرائيليه المنتهيه
ايرلابيد انه لا حق لاحد بان يملي علينا
اخلاق القتال امام المدعي العام للجنائيه
الدوليه توضع قضيه اغتيال مراسله الجزيره
شيرين ابو عاقله وفي ذلك اختبارا للضمير
الدولي الذي لم يتوقف عن دعواته لتحقيق
شفاف يحقق العدل ويكشف القاتل ويحاسبه فهل
يمكن محاكمه اسرائيل بتهمه اغتيال شيرين
ومن سيتحمل المسؤوليه الجنائيه الجندي
الذي اطلق الرصاصه اما اعطاه الامر ام
كلاهما وماذا عن جرائم اسرائيل السابقه
بحق الصحفيين تاريخ اسرائيل الطويل
والمثقل بحوادث الافلات من العقاب من شانه
ان يبقي الاجابه معلقه في خانه التكهنات